My favorite thing about this new house
is that there's a blue jay that lives in the trees.
There's a ton of big, mature trees around my house.
There's a church across the street.
They just have a bunch of trees and shit.
And here's the thing,
I. I will post the video.
I have a blue jay. Came to my bird feeder, like,
a couple days before I moved out of my old house,
and then now I moved here,
there's a blue jay. So it makes it feel like alignment,
because I'm feeling very shitty,
very, um,
super depressy. I don't know if it's, like,
summertime sadness. I know that's a thing.
I just remembered that, so maybe that's it.
But, um,
super feeling down lately,
and then realizing that the Blue Jay was at my old house,
and then it's here. And because this morning,
the blue jay was squawking so loud,
I got up to see you. Is there a problem?
And it was a blue jay. And I was like, oh,
it was like, what a way to start my day.
Unarudi! Februari!
Februari! Februari! Februari!